so but there was a lot that I wish I did
have with him that I didn't have and did
your dad accept your well your sexual I
wasn't sure because we never discussed
it I never was face to face with him
when it came to you know did he know
that you were gay when you were young
he had to have because of the way that
he treated me and you know he's the gang
member so wasn't it he didn't really
accept it but as he got older he was old
now now when I seen him for the first
time after all these years
and he looked at me he said well I guess
you know you're my older daughter now so
he kind of laughed about it it went from
one thing after another and then he got
sick and he got put into the hospital
and then my brother had said that um he
was going to take since he was his
oldest he was going to take care of all
the things that I said well why are you
taking charge of everything now you know
after everything that he's done to us he
said you still gotta you know admit he's
our father if it wasn't for him we
wouldn't be in this world and you know
maybe this is his way of asking for
forgiveness
so he did but when he died and they made
the
they made the funeral arrangements it
did Hit me hard hit me harder than I you
know I expected because that was that I
had the attitude I didn't give a [__]
what he thought or what was going on I
just wanted answers
and I didn't get the answers that I was
looking for it was too late for any of
that
so
but you know even now you know it's been
a month or so now and it's still hitting
me kind of hard because you know I wish
I had a relationship with them that I
should have and I didn't
it's hard for Hispanic men to accept
it is it is but towards the end you know
my brother is gay you know he's he's gay
he's a gay guy you know he this gay like
he has a husband
he accepted him but he didn't he was
constantly you know talking [__] about
my brother but he had never said
anything negative about me being
transgender so you're
two male sibling uh children yeah both
gay both from him the only children that
from my mom was him yeah we're both gay
what do you think you guys both I don't
know it has to be something in the jeans
because we're not the only ones on my
dad's side
I have a cousin she's also you know
she's gay she just got her um
she's transgender from woman to man and
she looks like my brother to be honest
with you a lot she looks like my brother
and she's just my cousin but it runs in
the family on both sides I guess because
I have gay cousins also on both sides so
you know it's kind of hard
but
that's a lesson you know when you know
that your parents are alive you should
get as close to them as possible
whatever you know you have that is in
the middle that is creating any kind of
animosity
push it aside because when it's done and
over with you're not going to be able to
have that Bond again you're not you're
not going to be able to say the things
that you want to say
any of that you're not what do you wish
you had done differently with your debt
I wish that I would have stood in
contact with him and I wish that I would
have just you know accepted things for
the way they were and you know like I
said a long time ago on my first
interview with you
um something had happened to me when I
got burnt on the head and he that's
another thing that I had approach with
them and you know he lied about it again
he didn't want to admit what was then he
probably you know never would have
um I still don't know what happened but
that's something that was you know the
past and I should have just had what I
had with them at that moment because he
I only had like maybe a couple months
with him when he was alive what could
you have done differently just forgive
and forget forgive and forget that's all
you can do because like I said you know
I didn't think it was going to hit me
the way you know once he passed I
thought it was just going to be he
passed but it didn't happen it didn't
it hit me hard because I wish I would
have kept that you know relationship
with him where we just moved on from the
past
so anybody out there listening that's my
advice to you guys if you have any you
know your mom or your dad and you have
any kind of bridges between you guys
close them up keep that you know
relationship that you have as of now
you'll regret it you really will
good advice yeah how long have you been
on a skid row angel I've been down here
off and on since the 90s off and on I've
been down here this time since 2016 I
came back and I did things differently
this time I'm not using drugs like I was
you know I'm doing my housing and stuff
so but I in between that time before I
came back I did prison time I had to go
to prison you know and it's not the
first time I've been back and forth to
prison and back and come back down here
and I used and I do what I do but this
time I did it differently you know I'm
not using drugs at all period right now
at all good for you
um drinking I don't drink no more so I'm
just trying to move forward what gets
you prison time oh my god I've done
almost almost all my um Teenage from
teenage to Middle adult life in prison
for what I saw with the deadly weapon
three of them were assault with the
deadly weapon another one was uh bank
fraud I went to federal prison for that
so yeah I've done time from the age of
16 going on 17 all the way till I was 28
I believe
I had a colorful life very very much so
and it's not you know even though they
say crime doesn't pay it pays but it's
not worth it it's not worth it at all
come over here Chloe it's not worth it
at all it's not you know that there's
not as many as opportunity as there is
for a lot of people you know some people
just don't take it which I graduate this
month this coming month from um Ultimate
Medical Academy
um a medical administrative assistant so
I have been doing something positive
good for you yeah
yeah
that's great
there's so many transgenders down here
on Skid Row yes what's that all about
there's a lot of transgenders down here
because there's really this is really
the um I can say the place that kind of
kind of not 100 accepts us down here
but a lot of them because in mainstream
Society you guys get more and more
accepted down here than anywhere else
that I'm aware of and as far as the
police department there harassed us here
just like anywhere else maybe it's more
so down here that's if you're you know
in their eyesight but there's a lot of
opportunities that a lot of them don't
take
a lot of opportunities to move forward
and get your life ahead but it's not
easy it's not easy because you can't
just jump from point A to point B
there's always the Middle Road that you
have to take to get there and
unfortunately there's not that that easy
of opportunity for us as there is for
heterosexual women or you know men for
us we're in the middle and there's a lot
of danger down here a lot of danger that
people don't realize but there is
and you know unfortunately I've made it
this far I know a few that have passed
away down here
but um
if you're trying to get your life
together this is one way to start down
here you just gotta stay focused it's a
lot of help with housing and
there is but there again if you get
housing it's down here they try to put
you down here first because these old
hotels that you know they read the sros
they don't accept transgenders as easy
as they say they do or they don't want
to admit that they do discriminate down
here they do mind you I'm just a little
bit smarter than they are where they
think they could just do what they want
with us and I don't I won't stand for it
you know
actually I just turned 56 on the 15th
wow yeah I turned 56 on the sixth on the
15th of this month happy birthday thank
you is it difficult
to age as a transgender
yeah
I really don't think about my age until
that date comes but I try not to think
about it because I don't want to age but
um yeah you still look great thank you I
feel it I feel that if I chose a
different path I'd probably wouldn't
even be here
because I have OD down here a few times
a lot of things have happened where I
probably shouldn't have even made it
this far but I did
I'm thankful for that you have a great
personality you're a good looking man or
a woman or transgender whatever thank
you
my dogs keep me going
my dogs do keep me going I have more
than one I have six right now you have
six dogs I have six dogs right now and
they keep me going because if it wasn't
for them I'd probably be depressed and
you know just don't want to do it this
is a pit bull right yeah she's my oldest
she's the first one that I got down here
her name is Chloe I got her back in
2017. what are your other dogs
I got Chloe I got Chase four pit bulls
and I have two chihuahuas
you've got your hands full yes I do I do
but you know like I said they keep me
going
these are my kids don't keep me going
yeah you ever been in love
in love oh my God a whole bunch of times
but I feel that you know it's not for me
it's a lot of stress it's a lot of
stress there's always you know somebody
that cheats in the relationship
and it puts a lot of weight and a lot of
stress on a person's shoulders and if
you are the type that I am that you know
I get violent really easy when I'm hurt
if somebody hurts me and it's not worth
it that's where the prison terms came in
so you know yeah
I'm just glad that you know my life has
moved this way it's not moving as fast
as I would like it
but I am moving forward
yeah great that you're able to get away
from the drugs yeah you know I never
thought I would never never thought I
would give him up because it was a
replacement for all the pain that I was
feeling your drug was cracker crystal
meth I use both I use crack I use
crystal I've used heroin I've used it
all down here
I just did all down here Chloe come over
here I used it all down here and I got
rid of one by one
one by one and I feel that you know
there's nothing there in it for me
there's nothing in it for me at all
period
the best thing to do is just you know if
you're gonna need some kind of
substitute to keep you with a change of
mind we that's the best thing for you
sweet anything else is just gonna alter
your your mind your actions your
intellect is going to alter all of that
and when it comes down to it you wake up
you're in the same position you were
before
clearly you have the self-worth inside
you that led you to want to get clean
let you maybe pursue a career again my
dogs they did it for me because like I
said they have replaced the family that
I didn't have all those years
and it made me focused if it was
Colombian Glory if it's not for me what
would I do what would they do but I
think loving your dogs is an indication
that you can love yourself exactly and
loving yourself is is how you decide to
get clean is how you I had to decide on
a career I had to if I don't love myself
and I just keep on going downhill what's
going to happen they're going to find me
a dead somewhere absolutely and if that
happens what's going to happen to my
dogs
the breed that they are they're not
accepted 100 you know they're already
got their their marks on them where they
just want to put them to sleep and I
choose not that not to happen
nobody's gonna be able to take care of
them you know like me and nobody's gonna
put up with all the stuff they put me
through like me they're not
so yeah
do you have any regrets in your life
no
no I'm not going to have any regrets
other than my father you know not
keeping the relationship that I should
have had but no because in order to get
where I am today I had to go through all
the trials and tribulations I had to
what was the most difficult part of your
life
prison terms it's something that I had
to adjust to I don't I'm not the type of
person that likes anybody to tell me
what to do when to do it and I had to do
that authority figures we don't get
along me and authority figures I just
don't have the I don't have the
patience
or a quiet mouth where I just have to
keep quiet and listen to what they say
because it's not nine out of ten they're
not always right they're not always
right they like to take that position
that they have and harass people and I
see that now especially that I'm not on
parole or probation or anything I'm not
tolerant I'm not tolerant at all when it
comes to them because they say a lot of
things just to abuse their power
so yeah
that's who I am dear friends
a lot I know a lot of people down here a
lot of people that come and see you I
know a lot of people a lot you know a
lot of people down here I know a lot of
people I've been down here like I said
since the 90s everybody knows me and me
being transgender
I think I'm one of very few that have
been accepted downtown LA from gang
members you're like a different Echelon
of this transgender yeah I really am
you're more respected than I am 100 more
even the gang members like even from
gang members I get along with everybody
you know I'm never called out my name
they don't they don't step that boundary
with me because I guess I just they just
know me for a different person you know
they don't see the transgender in me
they just see me for who I am which is a
good thing
because um that would be a whole new
episode I think the world is changing
too it is we're starting to accept
people that are in transition but a lot
of transgenders just they're so um
locked up in a box because of the
sexuality and they're afraid to just to
step out and be who they are they don't
know how they'll be accepted by um
the public
so to speak I have never been that way
I've always just been me I never thought
about what they think or you know what's
going on because I've never really cared
I've just been me
since I've been growing up even in
prison I didn't care it's I'm just me
and in there too I had my respect
yeah
who do you think the future of skid row
is it seems like things are shrinking
here it is shrinking but with Karen bass
is Mayor I see that she's cutting a lot
of red tape to House people and that she
is trying to make an effort I think
things are going to change in a better
Direction down here
I think so but it's the way that is
going with all these tents and stuff a
lot of people just didn't take him
what's out there there's housing right
now there is housing you just gotta take
it
a lot of people don't want to do that
because the simple fact they don't want
to go through the
inspections of them telling you when you
have to open your door to do the
inspections all of that see I don't have
that problem considering because the
dogs that I have they're scared to go in
my unit because of the dogs and I'm not
going to take them all out at their
convenience you know at one time just so
they could do their little inspections
and try to act like they're doing their
job they're not they're not
I bet you in two years Skid Row will
look very very different
yeah it's changed since I've been back
here since 2016 but I think it's going
to change a lot further
and I don't think in a good way so to
speak I don't think so well you're going
to have these people that are normally
contained in this Skid Row Street yes
they're going to be somebody's neighbor
yeah that's true and I hope to God that
you know they put them in housing and
you know it's fair not just to do it to
put them up in some kind of cage where
you have to report and do this like
you're in jail No it should be regular
housing like anywhere else but it's
going to be chaos in somebody's
apartment building yeah it is yeah it is
you can't just move these people into an
apartment and save yourself you can't do
that because they're not used to that
number one they're not going to want to
give up their drugs and stuff no they're
not giving up the drugs no for sure it's
not going to happen it's not going to
happen until they want it to happen when
they're ready to give it up they'll give
it up I don't care how many programs you
put them through they're not going to do
it
maybe put all 20 000 people into rehab
but but to put them in somebody's
apartment somewhere yeah yeah
so till next time public just remember
what I said if you have your loved ones
still your mother and your father get as
close as you can because you're going to
regret it in the end if you don't
all right Angel and Chloe thank you so
much for coming in again thank you he
said thank you
he said thank you
all right angel thank you very much all
right